hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website common today we're in
around 7 of the 2016 candidates
tournament winner of this tournament
goes on to face Magnus Carlsen in
November for the World Championship
this is halfway point in the tournament
there's 14 rounds in the tournament so
after this we're gonna have a pretty
good idea of who is in striking distance
coming into this round at the top we
have a tie between Levon Aronian and
it's a tag a card of yakun at the bottom
we have a tie
not the good tie that you want and that
is Nakamura and so plov now today's
match is between the guys at the bottom
we have Nakamura playing the white
pieces and Tokoloshe playing the black
pieces both players have two points
coming into round 7 they both have 2
losses in the first six matches
definitely not what you want to see they
have two losses in four ties Nakamura
probably has the worst of it he had the
highest expectations probably out of
anyone in the last round he had a drawn
game going into the very end on the 75th
move he did touch a piece that he did
not intend to was forced to then move
that and ended up losing in a
heartbreaking fashion
went on to not go to the post conference
because he was pretty upset and got
subsequently fined because of that so
he's just having a rough tournament so
many people expecting him to do well
with the World Championship being in the
United States it was gonna be pretty
cool if he came out on top a lot of
people now hoping for Fabiana Caruana to
go ahead with the American flag to win
the tournament but both these players
still hunt but they're definitely gonna
have to have a big victory today so
we'll go ahead and get into it both
players have nothing to lose might as
well play for the win starts out with
pawn to d4 from Nakamura and then
Topalov responds with pawn to d5 follow
my pawn c4 pawn c6 Knight f3 Knight f6
pawn III and then Bishop f5 and this is
the slob defense sometimes you may see
the semi slob or you play pawn a 6 first
this does block the light square bishop
from coming outside the pawn chain it is
very difficult sometimes to go ahead and
develop this bishop depending on how
white you know captures in the center
board here
on d5 and help like recapture so a lot
of times you'll just see this slob and
that is just bring the bishop out here
to f5 first and then later on gonna play
pawn to e6 now if you haven't played
this lot of offense or seen in
high-level play generally it's gonna be
somewhat of a clogged abort state and
more times than not a pawn to d4 opening
unless it's a Queens gambit accepted
line which this is not this is a decline
line it's usually gonna be more clogged
in the stern of the board there may be a
pawn to e4 opening up a little bit so
that's just kind of what to expect when
we see both sides just continue with the
development Knight to c3 pawn e6 or
solidifying the pawn chain as we talked
about here Knight h4 bishop back here
after it takes the pawn is gonna
recapture here on a g6 double pawns here
on the G file but that's completely okay
and these are kind of all the main lines
so both sides have options to kind of
deviate from that but they're just kind
of keeping it close to their vest they
don't want to give anything as far as
any preparation away so far they're just
kind of playing all the main lines from
here you know why it has a few options
could at play rook here to be one could
play pawn to h3 getting ready to play
Bishop e2 the castle on the King side
that's fine could also play Queen b3
now that the LightSquared bishop is off
the board can start to really attack
here on the Queen side of the board sets
go not for the rook to be one Knight to
d7 almost is always going to happen and
then pawn to c5 and nakamora splitting a
lot of pressure because this starts
where a bishop is now gonna have a tough
time to get involved into the action
sometimes you can feel Caddo on the
Kings side these pawns aren't moving
anywhere so it's gonna be very difficult
to bring the bishop here to g7 this
square here on a c5 is very solidified
well I can always push further with pawn
at b4 so you know Bishop here to e7 to
castle on the Kings side that's kind of
an option here but as far as getting
that dark square Bishop involved it's
gonna be very difficult now on the
opposite side
Nakamura does have a little bit of a
tough time getting his own dark square
Bishop involved into the game which is
very common sometimes when you're
playing pawn d4 pawn III and you don't
have your dark square Bishop
involved before them but pon c5 a really
really good job of just blocking off a
lot of the squares Knight can't really
move can't come here to b6 as well so
it's gonna kind of hang out on the King
side of the board pawn to e5 just want
to make sure Nakamura is not completely
dominating the Queen side of the board
pawns a3 getting ready to push forward
with pawn at b4 then Bishop e7 as we
talked about and pawn g3 and Nakamura I
think it's fine either way Bishop to e2
and then castle on the King side or
decides to go ahead and play pawn to g3
Fink head Oh on the Kings side wants to
make sure his opponent just does not
completely dominate all these light
squares in the center of the board and
now if we look from blacks perspective
he really needs to be somewhat
aggressive he just can't set back the
entire time you can see start to choked
a little bit as far as where he can go
his Knights here can't do anything he's
Bishop really can't do anything his
Queen really can't do too much right now
he can castle but he's just kind of
sitting there and allowing his opponent
to do something so he starts to push
forward pawn to e5 trying to block the
center of the board blow it up or just
push for their pawn to e4 is also going
to kind of stop a lot of the threats
that Nakamura has as well Bishop to
g-tube and then as we kind of see here
pani for Soto blob is controlling the
light squares on the opposite side
Nakamura is controlling of the dark
squares pawn before trying to blow up
that the Queen side and usually you can
tell what side one color is going to
start to attacked by which direction the
pawns are kind of pointing in arrow to
mo so these dark squares are kind of
pointing towards the Queen side so not
chemours going to be looking to attack
on the Queen side and so blob over here
his pawns are kind of pointing towards
the Kings side so his real threat that
he has is starting to attack on the King
side pawn takes on before pawn
recaptures now knights back here f8 as
we kind of said there's nowhere for it
to go so it's gonna kind of relocate
here to e6 and then try to start to
control the center of the board and the
King side up on b-59 a e6 a bishop here
a d2 a castle on the Kings side and then
Knight to a4 so starting to get of his
pieces over here on the queenside he has
an attack he can either play pawn takes
here on c6 if he wants to or I can
either push forward with pawn to b6 also
a threats
what white really wants to do is get one
of his rooks behind enemy lines so rook
here on the seventh rank is gonna be
invaluable thinking to even get it to
the 8th ranked you know depending on
where his opponent is that's gonna be
valuable as well it's gonna be difficult
for this King to really you know
sometimes they'll come to g7 but he's
gonna be coming to this seventh or this
h-file right here which white can really
start to attack depending on where his
pieces are especially if you can kind of
open up this pawn right here then this
dark square Bishop can start to put a
lot of pressure on this h6 Square as
well OC Knight to g5 pawn h4 just
forcing the knight to move the knight
it's gonna come down here to f3 takes
here and then pawn recaptures
interesting from Topalov perspective
that that light square bishop wasn't
doing too much Topol I've had control of
the light squares right here i hit a
great pawn chain right here it kind of
just looks like he wanted to start
blowing some stuff up he didn't felt
like he had any aggressive place because
right now this pawn just kind of hanging
out and the only defense that's really
gonna have is his minor pieces now
nakamura can't just take right now
because this queen is really the only
protection that the knight has here on a
4 so nakamura wants to kind of have some
trades over here move is Knight back and
then start to attack here on this f3
square pawn takes c6 pawn recaptures and
then Knight back to c3 opening up the
door for the Queen to come here to f3
and then we see a pretty interesting
move from toe claw he decides to kind of
blow up the whole thing and he took a
little while to kind of think about this
it's a it's a pretty interesting line
that I was not expecting to kind of see
I don't think many people were but after
the bishop takes here on c5 giving up a
minor piece for both a pawn advantage
and just kind of a sinner control which
you do not have a force after the pawn
captures on a c5 then pawn push forward
to d4 and so we see the pawn capture
here on d4 then Queen - a d4 now it's
gonna be real tough for the Queen to
take here if it was Queen to f3 then all
of a sudden rook to a3 and toke lavash
all up in the business of white here if
we see you know Castle on King's side
then all of a sudden Queen to d2 rook to
c1 you can see why it's just kind of
playing defense right now which is not
really the position that he wants to be
so after Queen to b4 he recognizes that
the pawns still kind of sitting there
but for right now he is up a minor piece
his opponent does have more pawns but he
just needs to kind of hold tight not
panic not try to do anything too crazy
so first decides to go ahead and castle
on the Kings side get some protection
for his King and then he can worry about
anything else on board now queen g4 and
then rook to e1 just starting to
activate this a little bit which i think
is really nice
rook here to a d8 just putting more
pressure on this D 2 square also putting
it down so the the Queen would fall if
the bishop moves rook to a b2 just
adding a little bit protection on this
beat are this d2 Bishop rook d4 just
getting ready to bring another row cover
here to a d8 and then rook d7 I really
like this approach from Nakamura he says
okay I know you're gonna play rook to d8
that's gonna be a lot of pressure but I
have the defense I need I have both a
rookie and a queen right here so I'm
gonna be pretty aggressive I'm gonna
play rookie 7 anytime you can get your
rook on your opponent's 7th rank that's
gonna be a good thing so I definitely
like his approach rook here a to d8 then
we have a queen b3 and this is
threatening Queen to f7 so this is gonna
be a mate threat that definitely has to
be dealt with very very quickly so we
see the rook f8 and then the Queen comes
back here to a d1 now rook d8 doesn't
have to worry about that the main threat
because it's not there anymore and then
we see the same main threat now a lot of
times in the past I've seen these games
being
drawl they have a threefold repetition
and then just say hey super complicated
it's not worth risking it right now you
know both sides are completely okay but
it's gonna be tough for one of us to win
but both both these players they they
almost have to have a win that they
can't have a loss in this position with
only two points through six matches so
they play on Nakamura has a different
approach plays Knight to d1 and now
Knight to d5 so who decides okay now my
opponents is nice not controlling this
square here on d5 and this is a little
bit different let's say we came back
here where the Queen came to b3 and if
the knight were to come to d5 now okay
now that I could just take here and then
if we see the rook capture then all of a
sudden Queen to d8 is just absolutely
deadly King h7 or yeah King age 7 and
then rook e8
it's just too much for black to deal
with but now of a sudden once we come a
little further and we say Knights d1
Naoto blah feels a little safer with
Knight to d5 Nakamura plays rook c5
decentralizing his rook and then King h7
and this is one of those questionable
moves I'm not really sure what so Baba's
kind of trying to stop with King to h7
it makes more sense to play something
else maybe rook over here to 8 maybe
start to put a little pressure on his
opponents rook down here a1 makes a lot
of sense in the future I can start to
put pressure you know as he's playing
Queen h3 threatening check right here
depending on where Nakamura squeen is
King h7 it's not right now at least in a
huge amount of trouble but a king h7
King age tooth now this allows himself
to get his queen involved and not have
to worry about any shenanigans over here
with Queen to h3 so that's definitely a
powerful move Knight to f6 another one
of those that I just don't know that
it's it's helping that much instead
maybe pawn f6 for seeing the the rook to
move seems more logical to me Nakamura
is that a really good job though so we
have taupe lava
the point of his minor pieces to try to
gain an advantage especially with
control of the center of the board
Nakamura has kind of warded all that off
he has both the rook the knight and the
Queen and turned the board he has a very
nice pawn here on f3 and Nakamura still
hold he's holding down the fort he
hasn't lost any material from that and
so he's doing a good job if he can just
continue to hold on you know things are
definitely gonna be looking up for him
towards the endgame Knight f6 Bishop e3
attacking the rook rook comes over here
to be the attack of the Queen first but
then the Queen's just going to capture
here on b8 after the rook takes on at d1
then rook b1f kill again say why did he
just give up his rook for a minor piece
isn't he just completely lost now all of
a sudden it's one minor piece and two
rooks to one minor piece and one rook
and that's actually that's actually true
I think toeb off looked at this position
and said okay I have no way to win this
game Nakamura has just done such a good
job I kind of threw everything I put
everything on that Bishop you know
sacrifice right here trying to gain the
momentum that didn't work so one last
two raw rook over here to b8
Queen takes rook takes here now that
here's the thing if Nakamura does not
play rook b1 it's actually over Topol
have wins it's a it's a checkmate
waiting to come here that there's no way
to actually stop some of the threats
that we have on board
rook comes over here to h1 eventually
I'm now getting the Queen here and then
Queen to g2 there's no way to stop this
and so he kind of looked at and said
maybe Nakamura makes a mistake he's made
mistakes so far in this tournament and
if not hey I'll kind of play it out and
then hey I'm not playing too well in the
tournament anyway so we'll just kind of
go from there
Nakamura though in this particular game
I was playing exactly how he needs to so
a queen back here to a d7 rook g5 just
sliding it over Knight to e4 attacking
but that's
I'm gonna go ahead and take your
material right here and after the Queen
takes now Queen over here to f4 and then
that is game on board just no way for
topple off to kind of come back he's
gonna gobble up material he's gonna be
up at least one piece on board and then
just be able to kind of run away with it
so tow blob resigns Nakamura gets a
much-needed win and he went from tied
for last place
to tied for second to last place he has
three points the leaders so everyone
else in the tournament in round 7 tied
with four and a half points we have same
guys cardiac inand Levon Aronian in
second place with four points is vision
on for know a lot of fans out there
rooting for vision on to kind of repeat
in the candidates tournament everyone
else kind of spread out throughout and
then Nakamura down there tied with
Fiddler's with three points so hopefully
knock more can kind of make a run but he
has a lot of room to make up especially
with most of these players at least
getting a drawl Nakamura has you know
he's got to win at least three just to
make up half a point for you know kind
of the leaders and the leaders Levon
Aronian and Carter yakin they seem to be
winning a lot more than Nakamura so hats
off to knock more in round seven and
hopefully he does well in rest the
tournament good luck to everyone else
for the second half of the tournament we
have seven more rounds to cover but
thank you guys for watching and I'll see
you guys in the next one